c'est la pénalité de la gagne pour le
sky rugby un succès sur le fil 23 à 22
face à l'entente menthe lit mais une
victoire importante pour les saint
quentinois promu en division honneur
cette saison
ça fait du bien de revenir avec une
victoire et c'est vrai que moi à
l'époque j'étais j'étais pas au sky le
capitaine y était et son mode fin de
match c'est à dire que vous avez fait
deux saisons sans aucune victoire en
honneur et de recommencer à landivisiau
heures par une victoire ça fait du bien
à tout le monde au moral
pourtant rien n'a été simple dans cette
partie des conditions climatiques
compliquées pas de grandes envolées un
ballon glissant les fautes de mains se
multiplient avec l'indiscipliné des deux
équipes la première période s'est
résumée à un duel de buteurs
à la mi-temps m'incliner mène 12 à 6 on
a commencé le vent dans le nez pour un
peu plus de fraîcheur aux premières
minutes on les en première mi temps on
voulait tenir le ballon et essayer de
relancer à la main et ont cédé en
deuxième mi temps on aura le vent dans
bond pourra sortir de chez nous un peu
plus au pied au retour des vestiaires
les nantais sont réduits à 14 ils
encaissent directement un premier essai
[Musique]
et suite à une touche à l'entrée des 22
mètres le bus de skype anvers les
joueurs nantais pour doubler la mise
[Applaudissements]
à dix minutes de la fin les hommes de
thomas payen mène 20 à 12 mais les
mantais réagissent et puis ils mettent
une pénalité un quart d'heure de la fin
et reviennent à cinq points et dans les
cinq dernières minutes une touche il
avance on fait une faute une deuxième
touché ils finissent dans l'en but de
pur il termine devant trois minutes de
la fin on est un peu en a reçu de
pression pour les dernières minutes la
pression les saint quentinois l'ont
gérée pour finalement l'emporter
une expérience acquise pour le
déplacement de dimanche prochain à cergy
pontoise pour le compte de la deuxième
journée de la division honneur
[Applaudissements]